apple just blew everybody's minds with
their new mac studio and their mac
studio display featuring the brand new
m1 ultra chip that takes two m1 max
chips and puts them together for an
absolutely insane amount of performance
and in this video i'm going to help you
decide exactly which configuration is
going to best meet your needs and save
you up to a thousand eight hundred
dollars by not getting upgrades that
won't actually help you we have done an
insane amount of tests and comparisons
over the last year and a half since
apple launched their own chips looking
at binned and unbid models the different
amounts of graphics cores cpus ram and
how that affects real world productivity
and all of that applies to this new mac
and with that we actually bought three
mac studios ranging from the base model
all the way to a fully specced out one
so we're gonna have real world
comparisons showing you the data soon so
if you guys want to see that make sure
you guys click subscribe down below and
help us reach our goal of 1 million
subscribers with all that said let's
jump in and i'm gonna start out with the
new apple studio display people have
been waiting for this display for eight
years now and i'm so happy the apple
price set at 1600 bucks instead of
something more expensive now that is
still very pricey but compared to lg's
ultrafine 5k that came out six years ago
and that still sells for 1300 this is a
much better display now when we go into
it there are not that many options the
first one is choosing between standard
glass or the nano texture glass now this
upgrade is only 300
where it used to be a 500 upgrade on the
imac or a thousand on the pro display
xdr but with that said i still would not
buy it unless you know that you have a
ton of reflections in the room that
you're working in because even though
this is way better than the matte film
over your display it does still limit
the sharpness and detail of this display
compared to the standard glass now along
with that this is apple's first desktop
display or display in a macbook that
actually runs at 600 nits the pro
display xdr for standard non-hdr content
runs at 500 as does this new 60-inch
macbook pro the 14-inch macbook pros the
imacs all those so that extra of 100
nits is also going to combat any
reflectivity now the next choice that
you get is the stand for an extra 400
you can upgrade to a hinged display that
allows for adjustment in height now that
stand that is similar looking to this
with the pro display xdr that i have is
a thousand bucks but what you have to
make sure that you don't miss is that
this does not allow for rotation or
removal or anything like that so that
price is just for height adjustment and
if you look at this image the display is
much closer to you if you have it kind
of in that normal range compared to
being tucked further back and that is
something that can be a pain with a lot
of desks over 400 bucks i don't think
it's worth it you can always get one of
those little stands to lift it up or
maybe even put it on your mac studio if
it fits on there moving on to the mac
studio we are greeted with a couple
options right out of the gate and one
thing that you guys have to know is that
it doesn't matter which one you choose
other than the base storage so this 4
000 option literally twice as expensive
we've never seen such a big jump it
right away doubles your ram and your ssd
so if you're somebody that doesn't need
a terabyte of ssd let's say you use a
server then you can go with the base
model and then upgrade the components
that you need now with that said with
this mac this is one of the few times
where i would suggest for people to
spend more money on storage in the past
i always said hey buy an external ssd or
hard drive don't waste too much money on
storage here but this time because apple
is using the fastest ssds on the market
and their prices are the same you are
actually getting a killer deal spending
a little bit more money and going up to
say a one terabyte ssd or a two terabyte
even the four terabyte isn't that bad
because if you look at external ssds to
buy something with that capacity they're
not cheap at all and the speeds are
going to be much much slower sometimes
even up to seven times slower than
getting it internally so if you're
somebody that works off of your system
without a server i would definitely look
at getting at least a two terabyte maybe
even a four terabyte if you're going for
the higher end configuration with the m1
ultra because you're paying a thousand
dollars more for this insane performance
now with that said another thing that
you guys have to keep in mind is that if
you're trying to get your mac studio as
quick as possible sometimes just
switching your storage configuration can
get you your mac one or two weeks faster
so make sure and go through the
different options now opening up this
configuration page the first thing we
see is which chips that you want and how
many graphics cores one thing you guys
have to remember
don't make this mistake is that when you
upgrade to more graphic scores you are
not getting anything else with the base
m1 max you are not getting extra thunder
reports by going to the 32 core graphics
you're not getting more encoders you're
not getting any extra bandwidth none of
that it's simply a little bit more
graphics performance and a lot of times
we're doing real world tests especially
with these high-end m1 max ships we are
not that limited by the graphics
performance so only a little bit of
people actually that are out there by
getting limited by that apple has so
much dedicated hardware that speeds up
specific things that a lot of times it's
other things like the encoders or
decoders so if you spend the 200 it's
not
that you know bad of a deal but you
might not see any differences especially
if you're somebody does things that are
more cpu limited for example if you're
doing x code if you're running photo
editing you are you will not see any
difference whatsoever but with that said
jumping up to the m1 ultra which has
twice as many cpu cores and twice the
amount of graphics course from the base
models that will make a massive
difference especially for things like
photo editing where the extra memory
bandwidth is also going to help and if
you're somebody that does 3d rendering
gaming or video editing that extra
graphics performance is going to be
massive and if you're somebody that
works with video like we do we're
exporting a video a day having double
the decoders and encoders is really
going to speed things up for example a
six minute video should export in under
a minute if you go with the m1 ultra now
here's another huge mistake that i want
a lot of you guys to pay attention to
this m on ultra with 64 graphic scores
instead of 48 is a thousand dollars more
once again you don't get anything else
other than more graphic scores you don't
get any more decoders any extra ports
any extra bandwidth none of that and the
graphics performance that that's going
to come with the 48 core already is at
such insane levels that are they're
pretty much meeting rtx 3080 desktop
3090 performance so unless you're gonna
utilize all of that and be limited
spending the extra thousand dollars
isn't going to do much now another thing
we noticed with these chips in the
laptops and also the charts that apple
provided
is that we don't see complete perfect
scaling so for example with the 32 core
m1 max in this laptop it did not give
you proper scaling compared to the 24
core it was a little bit limited and the
same thing could potentially happen here
if the m1 max model it runs at 60 watts
you double the gpu cores if you're going
to the 64 core model
we're not seeing doubling as far as
wattage in their charts meaning that we
could have a little bit of limitations
in terms of power usage and performance
so i have to really question if you need
the extra graphics cores i think most
people do not and the m1 ultra with 48
core is going to be the sweet spot both
in terms of performance and cooling in
that pretty small chassis now let's go
ahead and talk about memory so you have
the option of 32 or 64 with m1 max or 64
and 128 with the m1 pro now with our
laptop videos we compared 32 to 64 and i
threw everything at it windows virtual
machines video editing photo editing at
the same time and we saw pretty much no
difference between 32 and 64
using it in scenarios that nobody would
ever use them
and here going up to 128 is just insane
if you don't believe me go watch that
video see how well this apple silicon
with the unified memory works in mac os
and think for yourself do you need 128
it's a 800 upgrade if you already are
getting the 64. a huge price increase i
think nobody really needs that so there
you guys go i think the sweet spot is
either that base model for two grand
maybe upgrade the storage or the four
thousand dollar and one ultra leave it
as is with the 64 gigs of memory and
then maybe upgrade your storage if you
want a little bit more if you're working
off the internal storage it's actually
not a bad deal like i said we have three
of these coming in we will be doing some
detailed real world comparison videos
showing you guys the wattage the
frequency if there's any slowdowns fan
noise performance all of that so make
sure you guys click that circle above to
subscribe check out one of those great
videos over there including the deep
dive into the m1 ultra chip this has
been max and i will see you in the next
video